hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Lego world's now if
you're anything like me you were a fan
of Lego as a kid you built with them and
that's why you're an engineer today or a
failed dropout of an engineer who'd not
doing anything important with his life
ah make myself sad and I didn't mean to
what I meant to say was happy happy
happy I actually loved one of my
favorite games of all time is actually
LEGO Island that was made in like 1995
it's absolutely phenomenal but this was
like surprise released oh hello okay
whoa
badass I didn't know that I was gonna be
dive-bombing in am I gonna die am I
gonna slam uh oh well oh no I'm fine
okay cool
okay so like I said this game just kind
of suddenly dropped out of nowhere it's
oh that's so cool oh it's so pretty
who are you hi I punched her why did I
punch I punched her I punched her so
hard she went into the ocean I didn't
need to come back I'm so sorry I'm
trying to make this a happy video it
didn't turn out that way okay yeah okay
so there we go I beat him up I'm gonna
scavenges parts and oh okay I'm gonna
use them to build the world around me so
anyway I never played this game before
I've never even looked at this game I
just saw the gameplay trailer and Ross
actually told me all about it oh that's
so cool it's so pretty
I mean it's come a long way since like
LEGO Island but something about the Lego
styling of things and especially like
lego movie that was one of my favorite
movies in recent years it's amazing
hello yes
oh I ride my steed I shall steer you
correctly and I probably won't punch you
so I'm just gonna explore around a
little bit and see what this world has
to offer but it's so pretty like the way
that the characters move it's so cool
Nona block is sorry horsey I didn't mean
to wait he is so cool oh man I don't
know why
I'm so much fun with this hey maybe I
should go out and find that lady that I
punched hey I'm sorry I'm sorry that I
punched the only woman on this island
hello
you like my horse no don't run away from
hello okay I'm looking here now why what
was over there there was a whole lot of
nothing oh oh we shall ride together
except you seem to be stuck on that did
I mention this was an alpha okay
alright hang on I got to figure out
tools oh here we go okay so add two whoa
oh oh all it's so cool oh that's awesome
look at that okay I need to I don't know
why is it so cool to me and head left oh
good I didn't think it was Christmas
enough let's get some red and green in
there oh good
oh it's so beautiful Hugh oh look at
this I mean what else would you be
looking at but look at this I don't know
why it is so cool me okay yeah I am a
cruel god all shall bow down before me
sorry lady
I'm just flattening everything around
you god this was pretty before I look
not capable huh man I messed up
everything
Oh what did I do some yay what am i
doing
what did i do did I built a prefab oh
that's so cool what cool things have
people actually built that aren't crap
hello hi how's it going still freaking
out that's okay I'll just take that from
you um excuse me could you get out of my
horse
yeah I'd like to think that this is
actually a wall jeez hi how are you
that's not terrifying okay goodbye
hello oh you want to put up your dukes
well I'll warn you apparently I'm a
great ok you're dead now cool that did
the thing alright ok these horses don't
seem to like my terrain modifications
what no ways it's awesome I'm so good at
climbing oh this would be beautiful it
was I actually on an island good thing I
got my ugly ass rock wall over here but
one thing I can't say about the game is
it feels so smooth like all the movement
they did a lot of work on that because
this game actually it plays really well
it's as Erin would say it's got great
game feel cuz that's how Erin talks to
me I can put my castle on this hell yes
I'm doing all that with my brain I'm
putting them all pieces together with my
nose it done
I want paint it oh why are there
skeletons in it do I have to punch the
crap out of them oh that just means it
knew Oh where's my currency oh I don't
have any money I'm gonna have to punch
some things to get money out of them
this is grand theft Lego right there we
go got it found the right place so
apparently with this game it needs to be
mentioned that there is no online
multiplayer yet as far as I know other
working on it at the moment what did I
do
did I build a happy little family I
build a happy little family that I can
destroy I'm your doom high yo Oh Oh No
he's so mad oh god I feel so bad he's
defenseless well I guess I'm head of
this okay bye nevermind then
I live here
now everybody worship me and migrate
home I created it I can do whatever I
want with it
hi hello who are you
that horse isn't doing ok I Drive this
car I can really oh yes cinematic view
for the car what am I gonna do with it
where am I gonna drive it here I go off
in the wild blue yonder
oh dammit I broke my new car also the
water kind of broke in that one juncture
welp that's just too damn bad
heavy heavy hey you wanna fight Oh No I
didn't mean to do that
I'm on the crazed punch stabber huh I'll
punch you to pee oh why why are my hands
been cursed to only destroy instead of
create hello oh you need to be punched I
don't know why I have such capable
punching skills blood punch away well
there we go that was fun alrighty what
do I do with this responsibility that's
been given to me I should have listened
to uncle pen okay I want to do that
again hello punch punch
Oh body slam butt slam oh ho that's
gonna be nasty when it gets to you watch
this
well not what I'm okay not okay I didn't
mean to do that hard no I missed oh no I
didn't miss she just fell to pieces I
didn't notice oh oh that's how I do it I
can skydive any time that's really cool
whee BAM oh effort horsey oh I missed
horsey where was there a horsey I have
no respect for the environment oh
they're running away very wisely okay
bye hello new world
old how's it going I'm here to wreck
everything it's so pretty
ok my objective here is not to ruin
everything in sight I'm here to wreck
everything
hello I'm gonna destroy what I see yeah
whoa
scuse me oh it drops out of everywhere
so I do need to destroy things so I get
by destroying and by destroying I mean
body slapping I'm gonna avoid body
slamming divorce what excuse me how dare
you oh I didn't even realize what was
happening okay I know I just said that I
was gonna be totally cool and not murder
everything I see but she attacked me
first that was yeah oh is that a
submersible yes please it's it's the
submarine on land yeah there we go
okay oh that's so cool how'd it were you
hi hello nothingness okay thank you
or any way to dive there's got to be a
way to die excuse me
well I Drive my submarine on land this
game is so fun Todd what's that over
there
what is that hello hi I see something
glowing is it for me is it good is it
bad
who's that lava what burns it's
apparently lava and I'm dead okay
no punishment ah what that poor caveman
oh my god what again oh oh I get it I
need to buy it and then I can use it
forever that's awesome why is there a
submarine over there why am i going
backwards I'm clearly pushing forwards
oh okay I guess this is just the way the
world is now well this is beautiful at
least I can see myself excuse me pardon
me sorry coming through hard on em wha
Campbell Campbell hi hello can i trade
on you yes oh you gotta love so silly oh
you're so silly I love that that's
amazing
hello horsey hello lady
oh you're a man yeah ah sorry I did not
mean to do that I'm gonna do something
oh yes that's the attack uh hold a
younger one yeah yeah you better run
away you better run away from the dirt
big gamble
okay who's gonna come get you oh it's
coming you better run ah then I'll hear
over here Oh mom will get you
where they're ahead if I don't
get stuck on this tree over there -
ji-ho come get you
Oh get ready oh you better not run
away too late that other horse you
should ramble you we're not run brando
get you won't get you okay so this is
pretty much all that I know how to do
now in Lego worlds there's not a lot of
stuff to do customizability wise but
they are planning to add a lot more
features and when multiplayer rolls
around that should be a lot of fun so
for now just enjoy this silly camel
riding off into the sunset wherever the
Sun may be and I will cease to wreak
havoc on this poor unsuspecting Island
so thank you everybody so much for
watching this game I believe is like $20
on Steam play for yourself if you want
to have a little bit of fun you want to
get a little creative and if you love
Lego like me so thanks again everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
kids get your face out of my butt please
thank you
let's go my modern art here interpretive
dance there y'all gone out on the back